pour le prochain prix celui de
l'interprétation féminine fais on se
rencontre et mademoiselle hérin jacob et
messieurs par l'eau sorrentino
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je suis très émue et heureuse
touché de remettre avec vous ce soir
ce prix qui est dédié à une actrice une
actrice est une aventurière
elle s'empare d'un rôle et elle ose elle
aime elle adore c'est fou comme elle
aime elle donne tout pour nous offrir un
magnifique cadeau c'est celui d'une
rencontre qui nous fera mieux aux et à
notre tour elle nous fait battre le
coeur plus fort plus larges comme l a
fait battre le vôtre cher formidable
jury messieurs les précédents qui
remporte le prix
les prix d'interprétation féminine est
attribué à dhahyane trouver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
thank you so much autres jurés merci
infiniment où j'aime je suis submergé
par l'émotion
thierry frémaux et pierre lescure merci
merci mille fois
tout a commencé sur festival de cannes
moi on m'a dit oui ben rhodes
fatim mon frère donc il faut quelqu'un
de raisonné merci d'avoir cru en moi et
de m'avoir permis de faire ce film m'a
donné une force que je l'ignorais avoir
et je ne l'oublierai jamais le royaume
est mauvais ce qui en fait le film notre
équipe a soutenu tous les longs tous les
producteurs qui ont rendu ce film
possible les acteurs à qu'elle accepte
ce rôle je t'apprends je ne pas examiner
ce prix ouais ça rappelle un certain
sens de ceux qui ont été touchés par les
actes de terrorisme et de reconstruire
les choses et de continuer à vivre entre
avoir tout perdu
ainsi sachez que vous n'êtes pas obligé
merci
yann premières côtes en beauté ses 15
ans email en décrochant sa toute
première reconnaissance internationale
majeure dans notre pays d'un accord
d'une femme allemande qui pète le duo de
terroristes néonazie responsable
d'attentats ayant coûté la vie à son
mari d'origine turque et à leur fils ce
film marque est tout à la fois sa
deuxième présence dans la compétition
cannoise après inglourious bastards et
son tout premier rôle bon sang blanc
dans sa langue natale
nal non
[Musique]